what's up renee how are we doing so my
husband and i have had a dilemma
his sister has had a
on and off again drug addiction for
about 20 years now
about two years ago she started cleaning
herself up and now she has her kids back
and she's living on her own and she
wants
now for my kids to come over and spend
the night
yes and we're having a hard time
trusting
what goes on there okay if i have to
have a hard
conversation with her um i don't want it
to
deter her from how you know from
any progress that she's made i don't
want to be judgey or anything like that
okay so there's a difference between
being judgy
and keeping your kids safe okay so take
the judgy part off
and then also take this off of your
heart and mind and soul
you are not responsible for the outcome
of somebody else's response to your
boundaries
that's their choice okay
here's my recommendation i push back
against the idea of sleepovers in
general
i'm not a huge fan of them if we do have
them they happen at my house
and that's that's more of a blanket
conversation
that i have not only with you know
particular family members that's just
who i tell everybody
right my friends if you want to do a
sleepover if my son
daughter wants to do sleepover it's
going to be over at my house because i
know what goes on in my house
and mine's a lot more related to
internet stuff than it is
to um and running the streets man we
just snuck out i spent half my life
spinning other people's houses and we're
just out running this roam in the
streets
um just because we'd walk out the front
door at somebody else's house and
i the world's different now and it was
stupid then
it's dangerous now right and so i
that's all before we even get to do i
really trust my sister-in-law
you know what i mean and so i that's
where i draw those lines
is just looping back with my kids and
saying hey we're just we're going to
sleepovers we're doing we're going to do
them here
when it comes to actually having
boundaries with your sister-in-law
um if you don't feel safe
you don't you don't feel safe you don't
need to apologize to anybody for that
on the other hand i know some folks who
have been in recovery who are
incredible people and they've got a past
that
that man makes my toenails curl
and i've seen a lot of wild stuff
and now they are incredible people right
and i wouldn't mind my son
i know that my senator would be safe
there it's my baggage at this point
right
and so you just just have to decide if
you all don't think she's there yet
she's not there yet and don't lose any
sleep over that
if you do think she's there and y'all
are just struggling then um
that's up to you guys right but it's at
the end of the day all this is about
not people's feelings not people's is it
gonna hurt this is gonna make them set
it about keeping my kids safe first and
foremost
okay and i know that's a lot easier said
than looking
a sister-in-law that's what i was
thinking easier said than done right
cool real cool idiot now i gotta sit
down and have this conversation
i know it's gonna be hard there's no
question um an easy way out of that
conversation is a simple we don't do
sleepovers
i know your family we just don't do
sleepovers uh that's a simple
conversation there
if you you guys love sleepovers you'll
have a group of friends and family that
you do this all the time with and
right you know your kids are going to
europe then it's a harder conversation
and it may be that instead of coming at
her with a
um we don't trust you
it would be a sit down conversation
about we are
bananas about screen time we're bananas
about people going to bed
we are bananas about language that's
used in the home
and i've had these conversations with
people i love dearly
right um my parents are all about tech
and we send the kids over we tell them
remember
they're gonna my kids know oh worried go
for it
grandma grumps house now dude we're
gonna be all we're gonna get ipads
and we remind them hey we're those
lunatic screen time parents and my
parents are like i know we know
and then they go to the zoo and they go
play right so but i put my boundaries up
there so it's less about i don't trust
you
and more about hey these are my
expectations for every person on earth
can you meet those right and then you
are the one owning the boundary you're
not just
lobbing grenades at somebody does that
make sense
yeah absolutely and that can be a much
safer way to enter that conversation
um the one that doesn't wreck people's
hearts and minds and again it's not
yours to own that but i also understand
you're
you're a good person and you don't just
want to melt somebody down for things
they did in the past
um that's a great question i appreciate
your heart and i know that that's
that's a challenging place to be